hello
this is my pydata talk this is also my
first talk i'm very excited
i'm going to talk about coming 19
visualizations talk about
the qualities of the realizations and
also talk about what we can learn from
those variations
the title is the good the bad and the
malicious
okay so here's outline
at first i will briefly introduce myself
a little bit by my background what i'm
doing now
and why i want to work on the projects
then we go to the outline of this
project specifically
how we are going to analyze the
qualities of localization
we'll do a short overview of basic
scientific facts about kubernetes
because we're going to talk about the
quality today we're going to
talk about the quality of regulation we
have to talk about
whether it is scientific or not first
then
i will give you a criteria how the
review will be done
we will take several examples from media
and also from
the um scientific community and some
from which some popular variations
on the internet then we will summarize
what we learned
from this project all right so um
a little bit about me i'm a data science
instructor at the galvanize
galvanize is a bootcamp company which
does software engineering and the data
science instruction
tutorial and bootcamping so here's my
teaching model i teach my students in a
way that i want to be taught
before that i studied physics at the
electrical engineering at ufc
unfortunately i didn't graduate with a
phd in physics but
a mastering physics and a master's in
electrical engineering
i joined information sciences institute
as a research programmer
then left eyesight great place to join
galvanize as a
instructor i published research papers
in quantum physics chemistry and
knowledge graph
one paper for each domain you can see my
interest jump a lot
as many people who join data scientists
from academic background
i also publish a book direct quarantine
it's going to be released
in early november so i try to
create the statistical backgrounds for
people who have no stem backgrounds
and try to build today's statistics from
intuition and example
there's a limited time promotion code
for the people data audience
i will put the code in this in the
official github repo
because this is recorded yeah i'm a keen
fan
big fan of reproducibility and the first
principle thinking
this is also why i want to do this
project okay
so here's the introduction of the
project when i proposed this project
that is may 18th the covert 19
deathstall is about
30k a little more than certificate
globally
at that time there are already a lot of
validations data analysis projects about
google knighting
on the internet so i think okay maybe i
need to do something
so it is also a hot topic in data
analytics and science as i said but i
find some of the relations are flawed
and
quite a few of them looks like they are
designed to mislead people without
always limited analytical skills i'm not
happy
i think it's my duty to make a critical
review also
so this project target is beginners so
if you are
from scientific research background
you're probably
well trained to spot some misleading
parts of the relation
uh analysis however if you are you don't
have such backgrounds or you're just a
beginner in the data analysis field it
probably will be hard
or maybe you have some intuition but i
don't know how to do it systematically
so this project is for you it is also a
like self-training project for myself
i want to develop a methodology for
myself to support
the good the biot and demolitions
projects um in terms of
copying immigration so there are no
fancy machine learning algorithm
you can basically sit back and relax and
there's no parallel computing of
something cores
so yeah the goal of this project is to
educate
to raise awareness and find
misinformation
hearing misinformation means misleading
virtualization
we are going to talk about kubernetes
and it's a serious topic
because screen 19 has draw a huge amount
of conspiracy theories i can't
imagine like any other topics can be
more like a
messy under social media so we need to
first first talk about
scientific facts so we need to define
fact first
if you look at lookup wikipedia this is
the definition of a scientific fact
a scientific effect is a repeatable
careful observation of measurement
often comes from experimentation other
means also called empirical evidence
however this is kind of too
philosophical from a non-philosophical
perspective
we can recognize a scientific fact as
something
was recognized by scientific community
collectively
however one important feature is that it
must be open to rebuttal
so the scientific community collectively
which means majority
of them recognize it's a scientific fact
it's true
but if there are new evidence a
scientific fact
will often will always be open to
remodel if you cannot challenge it
it's not a fact it's just a claim and
the
claim made by i don't know like a
yes it just has to be open to rebuttal
and how about ongoing emergency effect
this is important because
people scientists researchers around the
world they're just doing research about
coordinating every day
and they're developing the so-called
facts so
if it's ongoing emergency fact we can
further reduce lower the bar a little
bit
it may not be like collectively
recognized by the scientific community
but something if we want to call it
effect has which
has to went through um has to go through
scrutiny
scientific examination like peer review
or double blind randomized control trial
for for example a clinical trial today
something um dr foshi i mentioned during
a hearing
that there is no uh like a solution
for carbon 19 is that there's no drug
has went through
double blind randomized control trial so
if you're interested um go check the
link
here is a short review of basic
scientific facts about cover 19.
if you're interested i have listed the
sources of scientifics from world health
organization cdc
and also department of the house and
social care of uk
so here are some important facts about
sukkot 19.
first combination is a caused by virus
we call it cognitive virus
it spreads through air and masks do
reduce the risk of infection
both for yourself and for others
kubernetes
is not synthesized it originally came
from an animal likely bites
is more deadly than a common flu choline
is also more damaging for older adults
and people who have severe underlying
medical conditions
so for people like in my age um it's
probably
like a that's really i think it's about
one over a thousand
but for people who are older who have
diabetes
or who have heart disease it's much more
dietary for them
so we have the facts then we need to
determine a set of criteria
how we are going to determine the
validation quality since we already have
scientific facts to back
we have to back our analysis we have the
first rule
the first one is we want to know what
information realization tries to convey
does the information agree with the
scientific facts
if the information the relation tries to
convey does not
agree with scientific facts then
it's automatically a fail a bad what is
the quality of the data source this is
also important we want to
investigate the quality of data source
as the old saying goes
garbage in garbage chart then we want to
know what kind of
plots and aesthetic elements do the
realization use
to such variation element how or not
so this is essentially a rough mapping
of the so-called ggplot2 grammar
digitality starts with if you plot with
gram 2 in r
you first consider the data then the
geometry geometry
basically means what kind of graph
you're going to plot box plot pipeline
histogram et cetera
then you consider the settings like the
size the fonts
are the marker etc you want to know how
data is represented and decorated this
will be
our last criteria all right
so if we have such criteria then what is
our steps to review the radius examples
i'm going to do three steps in the first
step i'm going to
examine the original validation just
take a look at together
then i will attempt to reproduce the
validation this is
probably the hardest part of this
project because um you will see there
are problems that you don't have the
data source
or you find like what you created don't
match with the original one
since you don't have the data source you
don't know whether it's they just use a
real data source
or something is wrong on our own site
until we'll see that we'll see like
how different cases um that could boil
out then
lastly we provide comments according to
our review criteria
all right so here comes our first
example this is a viral edition
um broadcasted by fox news it is a
confirmed case of kobe 19 by country
and this picture has image already
attached from twitter and it is captured
on march
18 2020 so that's about
eight months ago so you see this is a
world map
background is like a dark ride and
you have several countries and you see
countries without data the blue part
and you see several red countries which
may indicate i think
indicate the countries with high
confirmed cases
okay it looks nice so far so here i try
to reproduce it
so first i need to draw map and i need
to find the data since we're already in
november at this moment
and then our data um for that time has
been like a long time ago
i go to the website called our working
data which
organization it's a non-profit
organization and data source has been
verified to be
the quality of data has verified to be
true so a standard
um python processing of the pandas data
cleaning
and here's the explicit map from the
number of confirmed cases to the color
so um the
library i check i used comes from as a
list of country names so you will see
like here i
did some manipulation of a dictionary
called records which is it's just
to match the country's name and remove
the records which we are not interested
in
right so this is a code for variation
and thanks to this guy who provided the
answer to this question
and basically adopted his answer and
made some changes
okay so here is operation as you can see
we do have more data um because back in
march we probably don't have a lot of
data for some countries
in africa and south america now it looks
all good
and we can somehow to some degree
successfully
reproduce the original plot but here's
an issue
so if you look at the original plot you
will see
for countries with conformity cases are
larger than 50
the colors are all right so
what about those group of this red group
what about the exact number of confirmed
cases
so let's take a look if you resort to
these filtered
records you will see countries like
united kingdoms
and south korea in the states and china
they all have
country account confirmed cases larger
than 50. however
they are all colored right at that time
march
18th united states of america 108
confirmed cases and china back then has
more than 3000
so this is a big issue because china
effectively has 30 times more confirming
cases in the united states
however on the map they are all red you
cannot tell the information and this
information is important
let's make some comments according to
our review criteria
the realization like what kind of
information does variation tries to
convey
it tries to represent the number of
confirmed cases of kubernetes by country
yeah this information seems to be
conveyed to that degree because
different colors represent different
numbers of cases
the quality of the data source seems to
be good although i don't have access to
the original data source that fox news
used to create this relation by the way
this is something i deeply concerned
nowadays of a medium usually publish
their vibration
their tables but they don't provide the
reproductive codes
how they produce this data how they
probably use the data to produce such
validation and they don't have access to
their original data
i hope there will be a moment to change
the situation
then the third third criteria point is
like what is the um
they um what is the visual elements
that is a visualization creator to match
to map the
statistical information to the actual
visual elements
so to use color which is fine but in
this case it's a bad decision i mean
which is fine in general but here it's
by decision
so there's no real differences for
countries which that's total more than
50.
as you can see iran italian china
they have like a like italian chin has
more than two thousand
uh confirmed cases however um they're
just uh have the same cop just have same
color
as united kingdom in south korea and
also
the geological size differences of
countries also influence judgment
countries like italians iran and spain
needs more visual attention
so we have to always remember we
ourselves are
real animals you will see china you will
see united states
big right but actually italian
at that time and iran has much more um
government cases than united states
but this information cannot be reduced
from the value edition from the
uh fox news so that's
this one some are good but the
key information the exact the
differences between different countries
are not conveyed
i would say it's basically grade b
variation
if i have to choose from a b c d yeah
let's look at another one this is a very
interesting one so
this is uh new cases per day also from
fox news
i got it from trader uh it is captured
on april 9
2020. as you can see um this um
this picture was captured on april 9 um
by the tweet user but you can see the
y-axis is april first
so likely it is uh um captured in early
april
april 2nd somehow so remember this is a
new cases per day and the total cases
is already more than three thousand so
you see
this is actually less than one month um
from the previous good edition the
previous realization is march
18th and this is uh april like uh
april first less than two weeks the
total confirmed cases
grew from slightly more than 100 to uh
almost
um like a three thousand and 500 or
something yeah
300 300.
so let's do a critical review and the
first step we do try to do the
reproducibility
so if you pay attention to this graph
especially the accesses and waxes
we will see something interesting you
will see like the y-axis is actually not
even for example here is a 19 and a 100
from 90-100 the scale is roughly
discharged
but it's the same from
and 350 to 400 the same distance
here represents 50 cases and he
represents one cases
30 cases and 33 cases so
how do we like what is it like a
influence of this change of skills
why fox news do this this is a question
that's hard to
which is hard to answer because we
really don't know what they were
thinking but we can reproduce
this graph on a regular like a x y scale
where x is scale to see what's going on
so here it is i just uh use the data
um which this which is provided exactly
in this graph
and we will um plot them on with two
different scales
so here's a trick thanks to this guy who
answered this question
if we want to reproduce this one we have
to create it uh
interpolated data for our ticket
for our like data cases such that um
they will plot nicely on this waxes so
i encourage you to examine the code to
understand how the interpolation is done
i think it's basically linear so um
there are probably other interpolation
but i just want to make it simple
to avoid like if as if i am when
debuting the data
yeah code is here and go check that all
right
here it is on the left hand side you
will see the y-axis
is even the tickers are evenly splitted
separated from
40 up to a 0 up to 400 with exactly the
same
size of the graph this is also from 40
to
0 to 400 but the skill are different
this is separated by
by 40 and here you see 10 and
50 50 50 10. so this is a fox news scale
so what's the biggest difference between
these two actually first
look they may look very likely
probably you won't say there is a
difference however if you look
close look closely you will see this
point is strange
um i would say on march 29th you have a
data point at 246
new cases on that day if you draw a
horizontal line somehow this is
much higher than the data that is
corresponding to the point in a normal y
scale
um this creates somehow an illusion
if you do the linear integrate linear
regression
with the last variable points you will
see a slope somehow like this
right but if you do it from the earlier
days you will see somehow like this
so they are not the same but if you see
on the fox news scale somehow you see
the second derivative of the total case
which is the rate of change of the daily
new cases
they somehow look the same the slope is
roughly this
and the slope is also roughly this so if
you use this skill you may think
okay the cruising the growth growing
growth rate
of the daily new cases is the same
however if you use the daily cases
especially if you do
like a regression you will see okay the
daily new cases
is also growing rapidly this is the same
let's review and make some comments
according to our criteria
the variation tries to present to the
delegate from the case in the united
states
which does the data is assumed to be
correct
and um yeah it seems to be good enough
and we do see a line chart which is
probably the best geometry best type of
graph you can choose for such a
presentation purpose
again the data source is not provided
that's fine
in this case however the tradition used
an even skill for no obvious reason i
don't want to like
guess they have a malicious attempt but
i just don't just want to say there is
no obvious reason
the accelerating increasing trend
which is what we see is the daily new
cases is an action of the total cases
the total cases will somehow behave like
exponential growth
it is downplayed however this dumpling
is
hidden if you only see this graph and
if you only see this one you don't see
the graph
that you can plot on the normal scale
you won't notice it
i would say it is at the boundary of
misleading
it's a it's hard to tell no
this is our second one so here's
additional comments
if you search online you will find there
are quite a lot of graphics from fox
news that you
can find misleading this one was found
on twitter the image origin was
march 2014. so this is obamacare
enrollment
at that time um you can see by march
21st 2031
this is a goal and this is a total
number of enrollment under the
you have like a what to say for this
left it looks like
you only achieved one third of your
original goal but
look at the number like you achieved
about i would say more than 80 percent
of the goal
so this is an issue because if you see
it's just an asperger most part of the
asperger
is hidden in the sea in the water so um
there are two obamacare enrollment is
doing great it's not like you only
achieving one servant
this is a clear misleading unlike the
one we just saw this is
clear misleading and thanks to the
origin from mediamatters.org a great
website
um like i'm not a video with that go
check that you'll find
a lot of examples how the misleading
realization
try to by media try to convey
information that
just may not be true so third one
this is a context free video edition
very interesting i found it also on
twitter
not very popular but this twitter user
claimed that he
or she wrote 11 papers on queen 19
mosque than the sweden
um we don't have too much time to pass
sweden but sweden is actually somehow
like a
special case because it doesn't um have
the regulation that you have to
wear mask in public yeah similar
and i just also wrote wrote materials
for those
medium and its data analysis shows that
the difference
differently than the narrative they push
because they say they even they lie
delay
sorry they divided it they don't this
guy don't didn't write for them and the
normalized graph is below
so we will see what they normalize the
graph is and hey claim
copy 19 follow standard curve with and
without medication measures
this is a curve interesting curve there
are
four uh six different uh land plots
represent different areas of countries
you have a a state your mark you have a
country country country country
northern american europe countries and
they always also angular
belgium um not as implant no not europe
and the waxes
look closely at value between zero and
one
and the x axis you have zero and up to
eighty
four so or even numbers
but no information is given what this
access mean
no information is given what is this y
axis mean however
if we know what they mean as this guy
claimed
there isn't really like you can say
there are big differences between
these six countries six areas so what's
going on
i try to reproduce this believe me i try
it
there's no context about this relation
so i think okay
it has to be with mask it has to be with
a
value which is between zero and one so i
do some research online
the x-axis seems to be a time-lapse
series so
up from zero to 84 so i try to google
like a data in two months or something
like that but uh
i i didn't succeed i didn't success
succeed
since the y-axis scale is a float number
between zero and one i try to search for
the transition transmission rate
so transmission rate is uh um if
we are if we can choke when that change
should be already smaller than one this
is
the average infected new patients
by uh like new wireless carrier um by
the um by one carrier so basically
if it's one it means on average uh
various carrier will
create another very various carrier
however the transmission rate for
this massachusetts was never below 0.7
so in 2020 since the output of the virus
i feel if you know how to reproduce this
graph
let me know so i did go to a website
called
rt.live which is website created by the
founder of instagram
and it has it was created by uh i think
the two people who are
backgrounds in the statistical analysis
so because rt can only be estimated it's
not like
the confirmed cases or that's told that
you have exact data
so great website critical edition go
check out and also
um we also we're also able to select the
change the taker frequency so thanks to
this guy who wrote the answer
uh here's the transmission rate of mass
usage as you can see at the early stage
horrible like on average one person will
in fact like uh three people three two
percent
and it gradually goes down at this point
it is about uh slightly below 0.8
however it was never below 0.7
so what we see is not a transmission
rate
um so if you check the trend grow
go down and even you do some like a
transformation of the scale
it doesn't look like you have you can
have a 80 day range such that you'll see
such a
curve no i failed so
this variation is actually quite typical
during the code age
um people without analytic skills they
are not
really interested by interested in say
waxes in the title
x axis they just want to see what they
want to see this is a big issue
and some people just make use of that
the variation
doesn't identify what issue it addresses
just to say
was always our mosque which is always up
to the uh regulation
kobe 19 will just be the same okay
nowadays we know it's not the same
scientifically because most countries
have contained kobe 19
especially in east asia comes in most
countries yeah
because time will change by the time you
see this i don't know what happened
what will happen there but the case this
the scientific
measures the regulation will change must
will help but
in this relation um there's no specific
like a clarification of what issue it
addressed and there is
no specification about the source of the
data i cannot identify the source of the
data
and i don't think anyone can create it i
can't identify that
the relation realization has no label no
skill and no title
it conveys no information at all
all right let's look at the last one it
comes from a tweet
and it was captured on march 22
2020 so here's some codes and you can
see some interesting quotes i mentioned
in the queue
and the origi it's something originally
in ohio where 5g was first is first
introduced by huawei
however by october 2020 the twitter user
has limited access to his or her account
so if you create a click this original
tweet you probably cannot see that
anymore
this is a variation this is one of the
most popular conspiracy theory about
kobe 19 however edition
online so this there's again no label no
skill but
what are the uh like uh the posters of
this real edition
as they claim this one probably is uh
like a
part of relation by new york times is
the total number of confirmed cases
in different locations in america new
york was a hotspot
san francisco los angeles and washington
um seattle
this is a so-called total number of
installed
5g tower so more february tower in new
york morphology tower in florida
in washington state in seattle and in
california so the claim fail g cost
corporate 90. this is story
so i try to reproduce that the first one
is probably easier to
reproduce however i couldn't find
reliable data for the 5g tower
installation in the united states
if you have it if you you know where to
find it
please let me know i will upload the
reproducibility
code in the github repo so this repo
will be updated
if new data is available so this
resolution tries to establish a cost
effect
cost-effective relationship between
faculty target installation and copy 19
cases
the implied information that file g is
the course of copy 19.
and the variation shows two images from
different sources in parallel
but i couldn't identify the source of
the image again variation has no enemy
has no label no skill and no title the
mistake
made in this relation is a false
reasoning of causality
in like in plain english word the
simultaneousness if something happens at
the same time
or in parallel we don't necessarily
establish the causality between two
events
you cannot say favorite cos call it well
you can also not you can't say like it's
covered that calls for g
if you have covered in yourself energy
sometimes there's even no relationship
no correlation at all
not even quadratic so perhaps there's a
confounding factor in this case the
population
for example uh mobile service providers
will prioritize 5g tower building
areas with high population density and
kobe 19 is also likely to ride faster
in area where population density is high
hi
the only paper research paper i can find
about
the relationship between kubernetes and
5g is a retracted research
so if you publish something called
retracted which means it means it's
seriously flawed okay you don't want
people see your publication
all right so here's another interesting
addition
you can also visualize the number of
taco bell how many taco bells
you see this is somehow similar to the
oculi 19 confirmed cases
they're also similar to the uh like a
number of faulty car installations
if that's what they claim to be the
faculty tower installation data
and if you look at the population you
will see
indeed the population is the confounding
factor behind that and you can actually
justify that
with from first principle because
population is
like it influences the transmission of
kobe 19 influence the installation of
energy tower and also install influence
the opening of taco bells yeah everybody
loves to talk about
so if even if there is no like a
causality
there can be correlation and the
correlation can be pure
illusion for example from like like the
end of last century to 2009
say you if you plot the number of people
which are drawn
drawn in swimming pool in the united
states with the number of film that
nicolas
cage appeared in you will find like a 66
percent correlation
a this is probably courtney class cage
is probably not the reason that people
die in swimming pool
and there's another more shocking one
you could get correlation more than 99
percent
so if you find the divorce rate the
worst number of the wall street
divorce reaching a state in the united
states and you compare it with the um
consumption of a certain product you
will see 99
correlation which is total evolution
okay just
from first principle probably not all
right so
i'm running out of time i will just
summarize the some license i learned
and i hope you'll also learn from that
as a realization creator
for my students for junior data
scientists if you are going to create a
relation
first always in short quality of data
garbage in gap jobs
always like it's classic official
provide fully reproducible codes for
virtualization
so you're not only showing the final
result you are showing
the whole pipeline from data to
vibration
this cannot be stressful you should
choose the right aesthetics for the
right
information for example when you choose
color or you will choose
colors of confidence or you choose size
you should make sure you are choosing
the right visual elements for the right
information
to be ethical you should never miss the
audience
or your manager on purpose if you find
you somehow
mislead people make sure make notes you
don't do it next time
as a real addition audience i would say
that you just see someone else's video
edition
first always go check the data source
quality if data source is provided
check it if it's not go ask for it you
should identify the reputation track of
the relation creator
you should be aware of the relationship
between visual elements and statistical
information this is essentially a
measure of the license for the
creator for example colorfulness is
usually not good quantitative measure of
quantity
due to perception differences so a 10
transparency
a difference between a 10 transparency
and 20 percent transparency which can
be alpha is maybe seen different in
with nothing different eyes of different
people so
we should be self-aware that whether you
are enjoying art
or you know you are extracting
information so
don't be like a mislead because you it's
just beautiful
or it's just like a creative yes
creative
creativeness is important beautifulness
is also important
but always be aware you are extracting
information you are not
realizing i'm impressing like all of us
what can like
enjoying a artwork you're not enjoying
artwork
at least like you have to do something
you have to extract information
at the end be a critical thinker always
ask questions like a third reviewer
because you are the one who are going to
accept something so
ask questions and torture the uh with
racing creator
to get what exactly is hiding behind the
radiation
that's about it i hope you stay safe
during this period of time
and yeah hope to see you soon thanks